[Music]
i
should
[Music]
[Applause]
that's miley cyrus getting choked up
while performing wrecking ball on
sunday in tampa i
just walked away i will always
want you the 28 year old singer kicked
things off at the tick tock tailgate
before the super bowl
but she had a hard time getting through
her 2013 breakup anthem
[Music]
after making her way through the rest of
the song she opened up to the audience
about strength and vulnerability
wear a lot of glitter and i wear a lot
of armor and but i also wear my heart on
my sleeve and so
with that it gets broken a lot
and a lot of us have been feeling broken
this year in the audience a specially
selected group of vaccinated health care
workers
invited to the super bowl by the nfl
party for a good cause we are so
appreciative of you and all your
diligence
miley performed songs off her latest
album plastic hearts
including night crawling with special
guest billy idol
and bad karma with joan jett so kiss
but of course she sang the miley
classics too
giving britney spears a shout out during
party in the usa
[Music]
hey we love britney miley finished
things off with the climb
dedicating it to the healthcare workers
in the audience
this song is about never giving in
and never giving up prior to her
performance miley posted a video of her
intense preparation for the show
singing while on the treadmill
you